let's jump to this next story from ABC
News because now we're going to start
getting freaky there were more toxic
chemicals on the train that derailed in
Ohio than originally reported data shows
is from last night so it may be you know
it may be things that have already been
reported that people finally figured out
uh ethyl hexel acrylate a carcinogen et
cetera I think we know about this but
now we got this from The Daily Mail
don't tell me it's safe residents of
East Palestine Express fears about
returning after it's revealed there were
more toxic chemicals on derailed Ohio
train than originally reported and
thousands of livestock left dead
yo thousands of livestock let me see if
I have this uh this video here let me
see uh where's that video there we go
check this one out I'm gonna play this
play this clip for you guys and uh the
cage and this this is what I found
Amanda Brashears was going to feed her
five hens and rooster this morning when
she discovered them all lifeless
practically in the same position with no
signs of a predator entering their
enclosure I'm beyond upset and quite
panicked because this
they may be just chickens but they're
family that's right it says their family
this one they cross the line they killed
chickens damn them well they weren't
eating them I mean that's okay but uh yo
here's what I think I think this whole
town is blanketed in a toxic stew they
can't see and the chickens are literally
the canary in the coal mine and this
lady in the video she goes if it can
kill chickens now imagine what will
happen to us in 20 years and I'm just
like 20 years lady they're dead now
what's gonna happen to you in a week
here's what I think they're chickens
they're low to the ground the chemicals
are raining down on everything and
everyone the chickens are outside so the
chemicals blanket everything the
chickens like to Flat their little wings
and dust up the air breathe it in and
Peck the ground eating ingesting it and
dying humans aren't eating things off
the ground but this lady's walking
around outside wafting all that garbage
up into the air probably breathing it in
yeah I wouldn't be surprised if we're
looking at a few months and people are
in the hospital with scarred lungs or
whatever kind of damage chemical burns
who knows
that's so CR the idea of that like if
you if there's a massive amount of of
casualties coming in the next that could
pop up in the next couple months I mean
I mean I'm not even sure how to process
that I mean the chickens are dead yeah
one you just have to wait you just have
to wait to see if it happens that must
be the most terrifying thing about
living in this area right now it could
be fine it could definitely not be fine
yo they said the air was safe
residue inside people's houses but where
are you finding it are you testing the
outside's well you're testing the ground
are you testing the sidewalks like water
they're get they're giving you a
statistic that's easy to write I mean
some places are saying they're seeing
some detection I think there's like
Cincinnati's water department
um but that it wasn't a big deal and
they're you know I it's hard for me not
to feel like a lot of regional agencies
are being asked to suppress information
or they're not able to test fast enough
to get the accurate information out kind
of through no fault of their own because
they've never had to deal with anything
like this you guys remember the algyl
bloom in uh where was it Superior or
something yeah and then all of a sudden
these cities on on the Great Lake had no
water because the algal bloom toxifies
the water you can't drink it and then
within a 40 mile radius of these cities
there was no water everything was bought
up everybody rushed to the grocery store
and bought whatever bottled water they
could and then it was all gone so people
were forced to evacuate because there's
no water to drink the water was toxic
I mean people go through what four
gallons a day something like that as an
average person the person I think I
think they're saying an emergency
emergency situations they're advising
what is it like a gallon for three days
that's to drink emergency situation yeah
for an emergency yeah yeah if you're
irrational I think it's like a gallon a
day I think people go through a lot more
water yeah like yeah when it comes to
like if you're bathing and stuff like
that it's like oh there's bathing's no
question I mean the average person's
probably using like it's like four
gallons a minute in the shower right
yeah it's ridiculous is it really that
much I mean I don't know for sure but
it's it's multiple gallons per minute
well think about this how many gallons
of water can your bathtub hold and how
long it take to fill up your bathtub
yeah I mean usually usually they're like
I think they're like
15 gallons or something like that no way
too they're way more than 50 to 100
maybe the gallons in a bathtub yeah wow
okay yeah yeah yeah I mean have your
look look up a 50 gallon drum you ever
see a 50 gallon drum yeah yeah I mean
try taking a bath in one of those things
good luck I mean bathtub might even be
more than that it just depends on your
bathtub I suppose but yeah they tell you
like when a storm's coming to fill up
your bathtub with water in the in the
event that something bad like the pipes
get busted up or something happens you
can't get access to water oh yeah
there's 72 gallons of typical bathtub
holds all right let's see there you go
look at that right in the middle 50 to
100. the water is definitely the most
dangerous game because this lady's
talking about you know 20 years or
whatever it doesn't matter because like
you said she's coming home to dead
chickens now they're right there
underneath all of it down but if this
stuff makes it into the water I mean
look at West Virginia look at the amount
of area that is affected by this show if
they might be facing some sort of Health
consequences in the next what six to
eight months who knows where places like
Charleston Huntington and monogaili
County my district who knows what kind
of problems we're gonna have two years
from now three years from now it sooner
than that all right take a look at this
image me being generous Stu Peters
tweeted this out he says just put this
in perspective the contaminated Ohio
river is the largest tributary of the
Mississippi River
you can see the Ohio River basin this
whole area man so it's happening just up
right here this explosion
if all this stuff gets in the Gets In
The Water excuse me it's spreading out
over everything look how much of
everything west of the Appalachians just
just yeah man
yeah that's your water this is a big a
big concern for us and that's why I the
uh the the chief of staff came by today
and said do you want an update regularly
from the West Virginia American Water
people I said of course because
obviously I want to know as much
information as I can get I don't know
how much they're going to be able to
give me but I talked to them once today
and of course they said that it's fine
it's being tested we have secondary
source of water ready to go but you
believe them
I want to well yeah I also want to
believe that you know they have my best
interests they want to help me stay and
live longer that they want to end Wars
and they believe war is bad and uh
there's a lot of things I want to
believe and it might be fine today but
as we know water moves downwards so what
about three days from now what about
next week right and I think that the
people that I spoke to I don't think
that there's anything malicious about
them they were I think that they are
working doing the best that they can
with the information that they've been
given but do I think that they have the
whole picture I mean I wouldn't if I had
to guess I would say no because I mean
the government doesn't lie right what
would happen if the word got out too I
mean this is two-thirds of West Virginia
and not to mention I mean almost all of
Ohio but like let's speaking from the
perspective of West Virginia like what
do you think people would do if the word
got out that the water actually was
contaminated and they couldn't drink it
oh it's pandemonium pandemonium it would
be it would be uh saying a circus
doesn't even do it justice because it
would be way more aggressively violent
and and it would have just detrimental
to to no end you couldn't even quantify
it it's almost the whole state of Ohio
and like the state of Indiana West
Virginia Tennessee Ohio is the fifth
most populated state in the country
people you know like that there's a lot
of people in Ohio never mind the people
in Tennessee and and I mean this isn't
that one mile radius that we were just
talking about in Arizona this is entire
States effectively so there's
the level the level two people you know
to the degree to which people need to be
prepared is
I I've tweeted this you know I was often
that in the future we're going to look
back and be shocked at the idea that we
we would literally flush fresh water
down the toilet yeah like literally just
waste it there's going to come a time
where it's going to be hard to Source
water there's already issues with the
Great Lakes where we've been depleting
them and then restrictions had to be put
in place so that they could be
replenished naturally and and maintain
then you get other states like I think
it was Arizona that was suing trying to
take Great Lakes water arguing that it's
part of the United States we have access
to all the water sources but the Great
Lakes Coalition includes I think Ontario
Canada so it's like it's an
international treaty you can't interfere
with it but taking a look now at the
entirety of Ohio I can only say I
absolutely hope it really isn't that bad
but hope and a couple uh you know five
bucks will get you a cup of coffee so if
if it were me and and I was in the
direct impact area of the Ohio River
basin yo I'd be I'd be filling up maybe
I'd maybe go buy like 10 50 gallon drums
and just fill them up seal them up I'm
not sure if my ignorance of how bad it
actually is would it would be like
considered Bliss or is detrimental
because it looks really terrible but for
for as much as I'm actually like
educated about this kind of stuff it
could be actually no big deal I don't
know it doesn't look good though
all the Farmland yeah yeah I mean I hope
it's no big deal I hope everyone is
totally fine I hope those chickens just
got really tired and went to sleep you
know what I mean but I think you should
go get the water because it's worse
comes worse you use it when the power
goes out some other time or you have
that resource on hand my problem is just
there is no way to know and it's hard to
know that the only way we get through it
is just by waiting to see what happens
we are now in a completely defensive
position to this I don't even know if
defensive is the right to describe it uh
trucker and tourists in the Super Chat
saying what about the food supply
there's thousands of Acres of Farmland
yeah yeah yeah we're reacting all that
Farmland I don't know man that's my
point though we only we only have the
ability to react we don't have any
choice but to deal with the consequences
and that is how do you even prepare for
something that could potentially be such
a big scale like I said I hope it's
totally fine but how could it be they
just burned a ton of chemicals into the
atmosphere isn't this what
environmentalists always say we should
not do isn't isn't like the world
basically blanketed in radioactive
particulates because of all the nuclear
bomb tests we did there was something
about that I was reading like it's hard
for us to date certain things because we
just blanketed the planet and yeah we
messed up nuclear fallout of some sort
well that too we messed up no we messed
it up sorry no I mean we did mess up I
agree for sure that's why we have to use
like surgical steel coming from like
World War II ships and everything yeah
because he doesn't have the background
radiation inside of it so like new steel
harvested or like refined today is going
to be radioactive is that what it is uh
think so that's why we literally go down
and find those old chips because it's
been kept underneath the water and thus
isolated from all that particular that's
what I understand we like d radioactive
it or something somehow like we're human
we're pretty smart we can figure that
out can we no idea I have no idea thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time